and the Oscar goes to Cameron Crowe for  our most famous  [Applause]  and third nomination for Cameron Crowe  in 1996 he was a double nominee for Best  Picture and Original Screenplay for  Jerry Maguire  [Music]  oh man  the movie was a love letter to music and  to my family  so I dedicate this to all the musicians  who inspire us and to my family  Alice crow Cindy Weber and Nancy Wilson  my incredible wife and collaborator  thanks Thank You DreamWorks vinyl films  Andy Fisher Scott Martin  Lisa Stewart Neil Preston Danny Bramson  and this incredible cast and crew Kate  you're magnificent Francis I couldn't  dream of a of a greater way to live out  the screenplay that is based on my hopes  and dreams  so also wouldn't be complete without  saying hello to the master himself mr.  Billy Wilder so here's to you Audrey and  Billy and thank you so much everybody  [Applause]  [Music]